it's timeout for CBS deals and this
morning we are sharing items it just
might help make your day a bit brighter
all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping now scan that QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifetime lifestyle expert
Ashley Bellman joins us with more and we
are bright and shiny yes Easter eggs
festive today I love it what is this
puppy Okay so this is a remote retriever
actually April is Autism Awareness Month
and the creator of this her name is Pam
she has an autistic son who is
non-verbal and one summer misplaced
several remote controls I do it all the
time we all do it my toddler does it and
then we don't have TVs anymore where you
can just go up to the screen and turn
off so she's like I have to think of a
solution she did the remote retriever
this is two pieces the base you press
the base and it has to be 150 feet in
range of the remote you put the tag on a
remote control and then once it locates
it blinks blue and then it blinks green
and does that sound when the remote is
located now when you pick it up you want
the sound to stop you just click it and
you're good to go it's 44.99 25 off to
never lose your remote again this is
incredible and you don't need a cell
phone you don't need an app you don't
need Wi-Fi it's just these two pieces
and you're good to go how far away is
150 feet
a big around here a big old room okay
what we got next okay vanity yes okay so
I love when I get a facial to get a
hydro facial this is a hydro facial you
could do at home for under thirty
dollars it's 29.99 40 off different
um different levels of exfoliation deep
poor cleaning it's going to make your
skin plump smooth hydrated oxidized it's
so easy to use it's comfortable 40 off
cbsdeals.com there's someone every
beauty girl should have this anytime
this is on social media it goes viral
okay
what is this okay so Limitless Power Pro
go 50 off today to have a three in one
wall charger basically Universal three
different ports it's also a power uh
charging pad as well so you can just put
your phone on and it will charge there's
a digital display so you can see how
much charge is left this is something I
was just traveling with my husband and
our toddler and I'm telling you between
the three of us the devices are endless
and we're always losing power never lose
power again 50 off this is the key right
here just plug and go some of them don't
even have the plug which right and you
can charge it while you're charging yes
and then it can be a part portable
charger okay this okay so I'm a bit of
an expert on this my husband has gadgets
like this throughout our house he tried
both of these and said these are amazing
119.99 for each of them this one is the
NECA I'll start with that so put it over
your neck like this okay there you do it
and then pull down on it and I'm going
to turn it on and pull it down to your
liking and it's going to be like a
shiatsu massage I don't know it nobody
charged anything it might not be plugged
oh there it is there we go and you can
put on your neck put on your back oh
amazing it's going to alleviate your
stress it's going to release endorphins
all the things we need and then this one
is a compression massager the Healer
that one is going to you can heat you
can cool she's not even listening to me
anymore up to 52 off today each and they
each come with a really nice case to put
them in because again as someone who has
these things lying around the house it's
nice to be able to put them away I'm
getting this for Jeffrey Todd Jeffrey
Todd needs a massage today everybody
needs a massage oh my gosh this is
amazing I really have to say and the
price is incredible
119.99 each insane Ashley thank you of
course you're welcome again of course we
partner with all of these companies to
get these deals so to buy anything all
you have to do is scan that QR code on
your screen or head on over to cbsdeals
oh.com